it's a buffing there two times man y'all
make sure y'all go [ __ ] with me on Bully
and kale podcast
special guest in here uh one of my
favorite new artists man I'm fresh from
Maui it's like midnight for people who
aren't you're watching this whenever
you're watching it but we got the
midnight interview popping off finesse
two times man appreciate you pulling up
man I appreciate you having me yeah yeah
I've been uh you know uh just I was
telling Dwight from Atlantic
you ain't drop no whack [ __ ] yeah since
you've been out man you've been applying
some pressure bro that back end is like
one of my favorite records yeah it's
gonna be real hard for me to drop some
weight like I'm an artist I'm just going
to studio and putting [ __ ] in like I put
this [ __ ] together like I paint a
picture so
you you if you think you're gonna hear
some whack from me you can quit thinking
about it yeah so
talk about that because we kind of are
in the punching era of Music everyone's
punching in are you pretty are you
pinning everything
yeah I mean all right like I've been
writing all my life
I I don't think I'd never be able to go
in because I like the I like the one I
want you to visualize what I'm talking
about no matter what it is I can be
talking about [ __ ] I want you to see
it I can I can be talking about you know
I'm saying selling drugs I want you to
see it I ain't gonna just go in there
and talk about [ __ ] just you know I
want you to see this [ __ ] I feel like I
put it on paper it come out better yeah
yeah no I could I I feel that dude you
know it's crazy because I feel like you
notice the difference right because it
is your [ __ ] is very um
it is very visual wow you know what I'm
saying I didn't see this [ __ ] like yeah
100 man
um so you obviously uh I just watched
your uh your interview with Gillian
Walla which I thought was super dope
because I really thought
just from like a perspective of like any
young man is living life right now
there's so much to take from your story
and um I think that like when we think
about incarceration and
being at your absolute worst in life I
think that I'm sure
being in a jail cell not knowing how
long you're going to be locked up
I know you said you ended up not doing
the whole 10 you did five
um
but mentally to be able to like bounce
back
after you get released and like kind of
not let up if anything level up like
that takes a lot of mental fortitude man
oh definitely should I still battle with
it today but I still I'm still
transitioning you know what I'm saying
it's still a whole lot of [ __ ] that I
don't know it's still a whole lot of
[ __ ] like I learned something new every
day
yeah I might not even speak on her but I
was like damn I like you still certain
[ __ ] that I battle with like damn I
can't believe it should go like this but
I gotta do it like especially with this
internet [ __ ] especially with the
industry you know what I'm saying like
we you know what I'm saying just rubbing
elbows with like the fake love you know
what I'm saying like I grew up on
principles and more so you know like the
fake love like this [ __ ] get on your
skin but you gotta deal with it you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah deal with it
it's like the industry like friendships
and then there's like the real
friendships and it's like trying to
figure out how to like maneuver and play
the game in in a way where you don't
take
the industry [ __ ] personal and you don't
take offense to it you just kind of know
what it is and at the same time be aware
of like what's actually happening you
know what I'm saying right you said like
uh the baby uh somebody who reached out
to you while you were locked up showed
you love Kevin Gates those were two of
the first people who you tapped in with
when you got it baby like I just heard
baby was riding in my music but Gage
actually reached out like case was
reaching out like on like two or three
different occasions like you know what
I'm saying like but like when I got
around guys I could feel his generosity
I could feel like where he come from the
struggle the pain and [ __ ] like so so
[ __ ] like that like they gonna Embrace
this [ __ ] some people can just feel this
[ __ ] through lyrics like yeah you could
tell when a [ __ ] actually done
something with a [ __ ] I ain't
you know what I'm saying like all they
just they they putting they didn't
product did something but they're
putting extra [ __ ] on it right you know
what I'm saying like so you know you can
you know what I'm saying if you come
from that [ __ ] you're gonna be able to
you yeah Gates is also somebody who's
also kind of been into similar
situations where he was incarcerated and
I think that you know
how important is that to know that like
because I have family members that have
been doing
I mean over 20 years in prison now and I
know that like any time
we write them and we accept the phone
calls is so important but I feel like
when you get incarcerated did you ever
feel like a certain points of time you
kind of forgotten about when it came to
family friends whatever yeah but it gets
to a point where like you'd be like [ __ ]
don't nobody owe me no little don't
nobody owe me no phone call nobody owe
me no come and see her I put myself in
this [ __ ] you know you got to be
a realist when when you when that's
that's our part of being a man to me you
know I'm saying just being a realist
like you got to accept this [ __ ] like
you can't really feel like oh oh I'm
lonely [ __ ] you wanted to be lonely you
signed up for you knew what this what
came with this doing so you can't even
be if you do if you are lonely you can't
neither ones that do stay there with you
and do stick by your side them the ones
you got to cherish like
them the ones you got to really be there
for it and they might not be perfect
they might have flaws you know what I'm
saying but at the same time like loyalty
overall so if a [ __ ] be loyalty
a lawyer if a [ __ ] can be loyal
then anything else you can kind of work
out with them like yeah you can work out
the rough part yeah loyalty I think is a
long that's the overall quality of the
hair like this it's as long as you loyal
you you are we can work we can work
around your other flaws that's fair you
know and it's my opinion when it comes
to this [ __ ] so that's how I feel about
like but yes you get [ __ ] up it get
longer it get yeah it's [ __ ] up but
you gotta the only thing that kept me
saying was man you did this [ __ ] so you
got to do what you got to do to not ever
feel this feeling right here again
um
yeah I saw you said that you weren't
playing like you weren't playing cards
you were just in your cell just focused
on
staying right mentally right now don't
get me wrong I ain't gonna just sit up
here and lie so I never played card okay
there were some days we got boring
there's a [ __ ] like and [ __ ]
play a couple hands of domino a couple
hands of space but I never did like you
got guys who wake up every day and they
stay Mission like they come out they
sell with a blanket they they cause they
probably know I'm talking about from sun
up to sun down they playing dominoes man
that's what they look forward to every
day yeah yeah man like if you if you see
that [ __ ] argue he arguing about them
Domino hmm you know it's people like
that like that use their time screen you
got your guys who use their time
strictly for working out you wake up
every time you see this [ __ ] you
working out you doing push-ups he's
doing you got [ __ ] who who who
who like to go to the law library and
help [ __ ] fight cases and get
back you know I spent more majority of
my time like in myself like I I spent
majority of my signs time to myself you
know on the feeds we got MP3 players so
so I be in my music I get in my zone I
just I'm staying focused on the Free
World read magazines and [ __ ] and how
are you able to update the music like
like did you ever store to buy stuff for
every two thirds in the face and a Bop
Bureau of Prison they uh update the
music catalog on the kiosk machine and
uh you able to download the new [ __ ]
that didn't came out oh wow yeah [ __ ]
dope as [ __ ] what was like uh your go-to
like give me like a few artists who you
kind of discovered while you were locked
up that you like you know well you know
a little baby off the top yeah a little
bit about the top like I know I I peeped
him out like I thought I was locked up
for probably about 18 months yeah 14
months of [ __ ] like that and I started
hearing um I was hearing I think it was
I think it was uh it's my dog yeah of
course yeah that was I mean well now him
and Milos they're a lot of money yeah a
lot of [ __ ] there were a lot of I
like that [ __ ] hard I like them all
though too like you know what I'm saying
something like that I started listening
to this [ __ ]
um
uh it was a few of them that came out
while since I've been gone gone on you
know what I'm saying like a couple guy
that went out when I had went in and
[ __ ] but yeah you know like he was one
of the main ones I'll ride with working
out too and [ __ ] all right now that
[ __ ] to the little baby talking
and [ __ ]
what up y'all what's stopping the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good friends at my bookie we're live
in my room right now in Las Vegas and if
you're not in Las Vegas like me and you
want to gamble on Sports in the easiest
most convenient way you want to get that
money man listen NFL season we got
college football we got NBA going stupid
right now all you got to do is sign up
right now at mybookie using the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
that's right whatever you deposit up two
thousand dollars they're gonna match
that they're gonna give you free money
to gamble with so what the [ __ ] are you
doing inflation is crazy everybody can
use some extra money they're gonna give
you some free money to play with if you
make your first deposit using that promo
code bootleg up to a thousand dollars
they're gonna match it uh I'm gonna tell
you what this weekend
Cardinals versus Niners Monday Night
Football Mexico City
I don't like my Cardinals go heavy on
them Niners all right that's all that's
my bet for the week all right let me
know what you gotta hit me on Instagram
and all that don't forget to sign up and
get this money with me at my bookie all
right go to my bookie right now stream
games bet on them you could live bet
them you could do the props and of
course they got the live casino all that
mybookie promo code bootleg sign up
right now and they're gonna match your
money up to a thousand dollars let's get
back to the interview
um how much of your time were you
because you know you think like if
you're an artist you're a rapper you
have time to write did you get out with
just like notebooks full of [ __ ]
[Music]
just ready to go yeah I gotta keep it
with me yeah so you you still got the
notebooks I got it on me right now can
we see him yeah let's break this [ __ ]
out Drew let's see
because I always wonder that like
like I feel like if I was as talented as
you are I was like yo I'm going to take
this time to write songs which is what
you did
walk in here and say right now come to
this time I gotta follow the rest often
do that right here right now I'm trying
to make that money right here right now
like
yeah you got hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of guest verses ready to
go
now
foreign
Jesus
well
I bet hey when you win and you win it
let's see this here I don't want to
touch your bag I don't know what else
you got in there
maybe another [ __ ] hundred thousand
dollars or something who knows
yo all this [ __ ] so this is all from
jail yeah I heard this [ __ ] from the
jail that [ __ ] from the bump this is
crazy man is there any organization to
this you just kind of go through and
find out all this [ __ ] I probably drop
like 50 of them this is [ __ ] could we
show the show this camera this is crazy
that's my set right there
it might mean all right that is my
they're my m um do you you pull from
this still yeah yeah that's what I work
out for that's amazing man that's what I
work out for right here
that's amazing oh
yeah
yeah
rappers you still got it right man stop
playing yeah put that pen to that paper
I'm gonna get that pin that pet so I'm
good at it now don't get me wrong
something good at uh yeah they are but I
do feel like when you write it it's more
like every line has more of a purpose as
to where when you punch in I feel like
you're kind of trying to rush through
[ __ ] yeah you're just saying [ __ ] and
you be and like every every engineer
appreciated every engineer that I'd have
ran across they'd be like damn I ain't
never seen nobody record their [ __ ]
fast
I go in there like I probably could
knock 10 songs out
an hour I'll be done like yeah I mean I
mean I'm I've been I mean I have
recorded studio so I've been in the
studio with a lot of artists and the
punching [ __ ] I understand the like I
understand why people do it but at the
same time if you're if you're an
engineer I can understand
all right remember me back right here
this guy knows he's done it a million
times but no it's that's that's not just
it not just because I got it on paper
but like I said I use my time
constructively like so a lot of time
when I was in the sale I used to just
believe it or not go through this [ __ ]
page for paid wow and just rip it and
then by when I get tired I I bookmark it
while I stopped it the next day let's do
it again that's amazing man and now
you're sitting there [ __ ] by
myself and just go like all right they
just need to say this and they need to
come back like this anything
yeah yeah was it like uh were you like
rapping a lot like were you like in
terms of like
were were there any ciphers going on
[ __ ] used to try to give me the rap
but if they knew you were a rapper right
yeah but I went with this [ __ ] right
yeah I'm here to do my time I'm not here
to entertain everybody no I'm doing time
man now don't get me wrong it's been a
couple times where
screaming a couple of good men
a couple good men we getting to see us
smoke up some joints and [ __ ] right he
was like we're gonna speed us one I
blocked y'all two three on let y'all see
how I'm gonna go
they even [ __ ] the streets up with that
[ __ ] I stay out there man oh [ __ ] like
this so y'all I have but not just no
free just in the unit
yo you had talked about this a bit with
uh wallow about because I have two of my
big cousins who've been incarcerated
most of their life and anytime I talk to
them or when they would get out and I
would talk to them something you brought
up is something that they also brought
up they're locked up in Arizona so the
politics are a lot it's a lot of race
related [ __ ] you know but
um they would always tell me about these
riots like when the prison riots would
pop off [ __ ] would be crazy people dying
I heard you talk about you ain't even
got to be involved in it
that's what I'm saying like they were
because
she can pop out between some more
[ __ ] and that one [ __ ] that
that never liked at you and you don't
even not know that this is opportunity
to get you so because it's a
free-for-all Bingo but you ain't even in
it right but once it go up it go up and
then you got all the police are running
to this area when now [ __ ] stole you
up on you with a knife you know what I'm
saying like yeah it should get Wicked it
get Wicked like this [ __ ] it's a whole
different world dog no I already know is
it is it something like where you at
like was it ever a point in time during
a situation like that where you felt
like
you know it was close for you in terms
of
you know wrong time wrong place or
I mean you know what I'm saying uh by me
being affiliated with an organization it
hasn't been a time where I felt like it
was old when I was like you know I'm
saying you bump ahead with my
organization right you know what I'm
saying like you know because it feels
good you get what I'm saying like yeah
physical sometimes like when you break
certain rules and [ __ ] and I feel like
God damn I might not make it at this
[ __ ] because I know me you know
what I'm saying like I ain't good with
authority
I'm not the police but guys in the
organization I ain't you know what I'm
saying so I always stayed in some
[ __ ] because I went good with with I
went good with
you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
tell me what to do yeah and then also
[ __ ] I mean no matter where you're
Affiliated at least from what I heard
once it becomes prison everything
changes in terms of like structure or
the politics the rules everything just
it's a whole new game right no different
yeah
um
yo you got locked up in 2017 right yo so
the whole rap game was in a weird place
then because it was kind of like
obviously like
I feel like 2017 it was like Peak clout
wrap [ __ ] SoundCloud [ __ ] yeah it was a
lot of um goofy Antics on Instagram a
lot of rappers were getting signed just
because they were doing dumb [ __ ] on the
internet
um you liked it today though still is
but not as bad because it got it was bad
in like 2017-2018 it was rough
um but also like you went in in like
Memphis was bubbling right but now
you're out and it's like the Forefront
of hip-hop yeah Memphis Light Memphis
like that thing when it comes to hip-hop
I think it's the I mean it's I think
it's the number one city yeah yeah me
too and and much I ain't being biased
shout out to Atlanta and also I think
Detroit's bubbling right now uh Florida
obviously different parts of Florida
have been doing their thing but I think
just uh Memphis has had the choke hold
for the last few years most different
like Atlanta got their own you know what
I'm saying but like Memphis bring a lot
of uh Memphis bring a lot of the the
sauce the seasoning to the rap guy yeah
I lingo like a lot of things we say like
you know what I'm saying like the way we
deliver people picking up on this [ __ ]
and people starting to respect it more
you know what I'm saying like they say
we country but now they like you well
now everybody sounding like they're from
Memphis yeah exactly and they're using
Southern beats everybody using take Keys
think about take Keith yeah everybody's
using you know what I'm saying uh these
certain take you from Memphis yep you
see what I'm saying so man thinking like
2017 obviously Dolph is still you know
killing it rest in peace the dog god
he's still killing it black youngster
was doing his thing at that time
um but now like fast forward and it's
just like
man everybody's signing somebody from
Memphis if Gotti hasn't already signed
them
um and then you got like just this whole
young crop of artists that are like
just yeah I just think it's dope to see
what do you think it is about
um from before you went into now do you
feel like everyone's moving more in the
same direction because it did feel like
there was a lot of division in Memphis
prior to uh
I would say probably before you got
locked up it felt like a lot of people I
mean not to say they don't have issues
now but it feels like there's more of
like a unified front Maybe I'm Wrong
I can say that it's just for business
which is all right right I mean you know
yeah but I guess I guess you could say
that you know but I mean if you respect
money I don't respect money that's fair
I don't expect money so you know like if
I [ __ ] with y'all Focus but I'm I'm
still getting over the hump of or not
respect the money
you see what I'm saying because
like you it's it gets it's to the point
now where like you know how they say
you know how they say a lot of people be
be
a sheep and wolves clothing definitely I
feel like today you got to be a a wolf
in sheep clothing
that's good you get what I'm saying like
you got to like like they see a real one
coming they see somebody who really
authentic and really about it
they they tend to stray away from me
they almost want you to be
your worst self yeah they almost watch
they're they're scared of of you so you
got to be you got to play extra nice you
got to be a wolf but you got to put on
sheep clothing but and back in the days
it was I ain't [ __ ] sheeps and wolves
clothing right but now it's vice versa
like you got to be a wolf if you're a
wolf you got to put on sheep clothing
like like they say like a wolf run into
a pack of sheep yeah everybody gonna
scream but if you're a wolf and you put
on some sheep clothing you might get a
little something you might get into some
rooms or you you gotta blend in you got
to blend in because like if you try to
just be too real too authentic they're
gonna shut you out they ain't gonna so
that's what hurt me the most because I
can't be who I am
I can't be who I am like not far on the
violent tip but I can't say what I want
to say like I can't you know what I'm
saying because it'll [ __ ] up so much so
much business right and it's like
especially nowadays because
you see a man this cancer culture [ __ ]
is real and [ __ ] just so like
worried about like the brand or worried
about like you know like I think I think
you you hit it on the head I think
nowadays you got to kind of
you know
you got to fake it till you make it you
got to play the game to a sense man and
I think that's I mean that's always been
the case you know but I think a lot of
people have kind of didn't know because
back then like Tupac them they would be
in them I was gonna say but I think a
lot of people in the last like four or
five years since since you know you've
been down have probably
showed you the path not to go they kind
of made those mistakes for a guy like
you to come in and see that and be like
oh well look I'm gonna move this way
because there's a bigger picture there's
a bigger play here I got I had to deal
with the program yeah I had to get with
I'm looking at but but I'm but I'm not
belittling anymore I'm not saying they
lived in a man I'm I'm saying they smart
yeah of course they smart but at the
same time though like the part that hurt
me is like don't act like that when you
really ain't liked it you see what I'm
saying like they get your money also
like I think too like with anything you
should want to have growth right then go
you know what I'm saying so like while
you still want to be yourself right in
order for you to grow fully whether
that's bring your family to certain
things that you know give them certain
things that they never had before
establish certain situations for your
career right
um that are bigger than just the rap
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying we just
saw Yo Gotti Buy the [ __ ] soccer team
you know what I'm saying that's the kind
of [ __ ] I feel like you know at the end
of the day nobody wants to stay the same
But to answer your question it's getting
better it's getting better and I think
like the situation me and money bad your
head I believe that helped a lot of
people out you know what I'm saying like
me and him come me and him reuniting and
coming back together and showing the
city the culture like like you can you
can't get over to move past stuff yeah
you can you know I haven't seen I didn't
see any real gangsters like in the
streets that have bodies on both sides I
just seen them come together just for
the for the you know what I'm saying
like you know what I'm saying for the
betterment of the youth you know so I
haven't seen it you know so it could be
done but a lot of people pride in a way
and then his new generation they just I
don't know what up we got to stop the
interview real quick we're live in Vegas
right now uh listen fellas if you're
watching this and you need a little
extra pep in your step you know what
step I'm talking about I'm talking about
that dick step damn it all right if you
need some help with that dick of yours
uh Pluto is here to save the day that's
right same exact ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis but here's the catch no
awkward doctor's appointments it comes
straight to your door in a chewable form
very discreet packaging very discreet
billing uh you don't have to go to a
random waiting room while you wait to
get your dick pills from the doctor it's
an embarrassing situation no with
Bluetooth all you do is go to
bluetooth.com right now sign up with the
promo code bootleg that's the most
important part when you sign up with
bootleg at bluetooth.com you get your
first month for free you just got to pay
five dollars shipping that's right you
go to Bluetooth you get the same active
ingredients as via Cialis in that blue
True Form your dick is uh on an all-time
high I mean this thing is [ __ ]
booming uh and then on the other end
they just dropped their new mint
chewable which has the same active
ingredients as Levitra all right which
is even stronger so if you really need
some help in the dick Department
bluetooth's got you all right go get a
free month fellas I don't care if you're
not even dealing with any dick problems
maybe you just want to impress somebody
you're about to [ __ ] Hammer all right
go to Bluetooth get your first month for
free right now delivered right to your
doorstep using that promo code bootleg
go do that and let's get back to the
interview
yeah I'm not familiar with uh whether or
not you had a relationship with Dolph or
whether or not it was good or bad but
obviously losing him for the City of
Memphis was a big deal
um for hip-hop in general
um what what was the you know the the
severity of that loss just for the scene
out there man
I mean like I said I was incarcerated
when it happened right so I couldn't I
didn't really just feel that fake I just
knew it was [ __ ] up damn like
like damn like you know what I'm saying
but I never got the full effect
you know what I'm saying because but now
that I'm out here and I'm like damn no
dope
you know what I'm saying but you know
when it comes to death I embrace death
like that's on some personal [ __ ] that's
a whole nother conversation but I don't
look at death too bad like I embrace it
like it is what it is
yeah I mean I feel like two if you live
a certain way you kind of got to brace
yourself for death yeah at all times and
not just if you live a certain way it
could be in about not to knock on wood
but you can even have a rig right it's
written whatever's gonna happen gonna
happen all you could do is try to
prevent it the best way you can but when
it's your time it's your time you can't
run from it it's one thing you can't run
from you can't run from it so when it
comes to them like I ain't the one to
just be like uh because I I'm a really
like I understand it gotta happen
a guy and I know it's a conversation
that [ __ ] don't like the hell
but yeah
I ain't gonna lie to myself that's fair
man something else that uh obviously uh
you speak about in your music uh yo talk
about because I think a lot of people
don't realize like the pimping culture
in Memphis is like a big deal you know
what I'm saying
um that is like kind of like a side to
the to the
game uh obviously it is the game but
aside to the
streets that I don't think we hear about
enough anymore
because when I was a kid we had so many
artists like too short
just so many artists do or die you know
what I'm saying and and I don't you
don't hear about it as much anymore in
music
um how big uh is that culture in Memphis
still to this day like not to say you're
involved in Idaho
Memphis no Memphis time for making Easy
Money pimping hoes in style yeah making
easy money paper hoes it's serious
you know what I'm saying and like like I
tell everybody like that this
conversation come up like Memphis
Memphis is in Memphis Pippin is like
selling weed
it's different breakage though like you
got you got [ __ ] who pimp Junkies you
got you know what I'm saying like it's
just different Breakers you got [ __ ]
who you know what I'm saying it's just
same [ __ ] it's people who sell [ __ ]
fentanyl lace drugs
it's just in your it's just in your
blood who's self [ __ ] you got lame
[ __ ] you ain't even got to be a
gangster to be a pimp right you ain't
got to be a killer to be a pimp like you
could be a straight lame and dude you
got [ __ ] that ain't gone I ain't gone
bust a grape and Welch's yard like but
they pimping like right you know and I
tell you hey Pam it's a non-contact
sport P like they don't want no problem
I want nothing to do with no smoke you
know what I'm saying but there's some
pipping so if the brackets are pimping
uh dope fiends what's the highest
bracket the highest breaker when you get
up incorporate like extortion and like
if a senator comes to town no extortion
it'll get crazy I ain't gonna put out it
out there but it get crazy it's a darker
side to it like like if a private
investigator like needs a girl to set up
some rich guy
no take some crazy pictures like you
don't usually see it in the movies in
that Bingo now you're bugging up the
right shoes look I I need you to get
this Senator butt ass naked strapped to
a [ __ ] bed and I'm gonna have
somebody across them like porn stars
your own porn company like it get deep
like it it get a whole lot more people
yo but when you went in like only fans
wasn't popping right no so not only fans
is like this whole page would pop
Backpage rest in peace
treat Willie no no
listen I'm a married man but I I am very
aware that Backpage is no longer a thing
first they got rid of Craigslist and
then Backpage with now the [ __ ] are
on only fans yeah I don't even know I
mean you still don't understand on the
fan
you know a lot of guys are like managing
women on only fans I have friends who do
it there's rappers who do it uh who were
we just talking to the managers girls
no not a little pump
tiger does it uh Adam 22 from no jumper
does it but I feel like it's kind of
like
I guess it's kind of like uh having your
own porn site but it's like it's like
you know instead of you get paid once
like 800 to shoot a scene
you get paid residual income off your
content so I think a lot of women
you know are I thought you were gonna
hit that [ __ ] are you I mean
this guy bring that thing over here
on camera
this
is a monster this is a [ __ ] this is a
finger oh my God a whole gorilla Frank
going up
oh wait you cut it in half it okay
it actually got small fast
[ __ ]
yeah no but only fans man shout out to
only fans
the pandemic had that [ __ ]
no I don't spend any money you can get
all the only fans content for free on
Reddit
that's neither here nor there
but he's yeah so in 2017 Backpage was
still a thing that's crazy I feel like
Backpage has been gone for like 10 years
yeah shout out to Backpage
when I was a kid there was a streak in
Phoenix Arizona called Van Buren
and it was uh like the main track right
so we would like
I was like 12 13 my cousin was 15 we
take my parents car and we used to ride
up and down Van Buren
[ __ ] with prostitutes
we'd like we would just troll them we
would throw water balloons at them all
kinds of [ __ ] but it was it's crazy we
got chased by a pimp once actually it's
oh yeah yeah because we we hit a chick
with a water balloon and uh and then we
got chased down by a dude in an Escalade
and we got away but it was it was pretty
[ __ ] it was crazy because now like
the internet just changed the whole [ __ ]
it's wild
um but yeah the world has changed since
you've gotten out
um I'm loving just man I was I was
telling Dwight yo one of my favorite
records is back in record Bros
I I when I first heard that record I was
like oh this dude is like special yeah
you know what I'm saying like I feel
like
I can't wait to hear what the album is
sounding like all right
it's gonna be one of them things
I let you hear one or two on before we
leave what is uh for you this album it's
got it's got to be a big statement for
you
um
when are we getting the album I know we
know Gucci's on the album obviously that
record's out when you're releasing this
we'll probably put this uh what's today
we'll probably put it out for Friday
Friday or Monday I can't expose the
release date yet then but it's coming
soon coming soon yeah if it was gonna be
after the day out because I'm gonna
announce it soon soon but I don't wanna
[ __ ] up the announcement day so that's
fair but I I give you a couple on before
we leave but yeah this [ __ ] this [ __ ] if
it'll be amazing like outside of Gucci
horse do we have any we got quavo on
there we got uh we got the baby and we
got uh Gucci Mane we said him and uh we
got a money bag yo of course yeah I got
my bag going now so this shit's gonna be
yeah like it's next level yeah it's
gonna be hard like this is what the
Street's been missing like I know that
what do you because you know from your
perspective what's missing and beside
yourself just in terms of content in
terms of musically what do you think is
missing that you're providing
staying hard on a [ __ ]
the way this the way the [ __ ] is hard
on a [ __ ] and then they just buying
down tricking and buying all type of
[ __ ] right like which is cool like I
ain't tripping like do your thing like
but don't you you [ __ ] the game up
just out here buying [ __ ] like because
now he's making it making it hard for a
[ __ ] to just hit the [ __ ] for free how
the [ __ ] I'm gonna come how the [ __ ] I'm
gonna compete with a [ __ ] go bounce
[ __ ] buying a [ __ ] a [ __ ] Birkin
bag yeah I'm gonna compete with that car
I ain't got nothing but a meal foreign
like like they've been going too ham
like it's time I tilt the scales back
I'm from Memphis we don't do that yeah
we don't we don't get down like that
like you know I'm saying but I get it
man but them [ __ ] and [ __ ] the streets
up like while I'm in jail like they like
my sister said I'm like yeah then I'm
listening to the city girl I'm listening
to everybody break a treat and then I'm
like damn they hard on the boys out
there man like I'm like nah man I got to
stand up for this [ __ ] I'm from Memphis
like so now he's like nah [ __ ] sock it
to my pockets
so now I'm trying to make all the the
real men like now I beat socket to my
pocket put it in my meat let me get that
so hopefully I'll be the one that
changed the wave you're gonna tilt the
scales back in the other direction yeah
man we can't be going for this [ __ ] yeah
make them make them all come clean they
were here to yeah come clean like the
water machine them all need to what they
were doing back in the day putting a
[ __ ] hand is gonna go back to this
[ __ ] with me it ain't gonna be this
no more like no like we can't set up a
whole generation of young women to think
that they could just be pretty and get
rich off of dude exactly exactly we
ain't going for this [ __ ] he said put it
in my mid put it in my meeting
hey what up y'all bootleg cab got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
the number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to Jardin in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg cab sent me they're
gonna take care of you at hardean when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
hardeen is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow them one more
time that's Hardy in underscore Las
Vegas let's get back to the interview
how did you end up linking up with uh
with mob ties and uh Jay Prince Jr
um I was doing time and uh I had heard
about them I I actually I actually had I
already won the work with them you know
before I met them but I met him through
uh I met him through one late artist
named Brazen I met him that's how we
like literally Linked In you know what
I'm saying like and I found out he was
going to say a fan of my music and [ __ ]
so I ended up traveling a little with
him and [ __ ] we clicked instantly like
before before any type of contract or
anything he was there for me you know
I'm saying [ __ ] with me and [ __ ] the
long way I feel like uh people who don't
know this is the guy who discovered
Drake right you know what I'm saying
right
I would hope naturally I could just see
Drake just just randomly jumping on a
song out of nowhere like the back end
remix or something or
has Drake listen to your [ __ ] like is he
a fantastic or at least no information
just no you guys have a song together no
it'd be cool do you have something
that'd be cool
it's gonna [ __ ] the street such a way so
if the drag vocals came in uh
you know
you know you'll see what will we see
you'll see I got a lot of big surprise
going on you know some might say Drake
has a lot to do with the Simpson though
so there might be a clash in uh in mine
States when it comes to females
uh he is the same God
he's the sixth God and he is the Sim god
he might be the ultimate trick and
that's okay
no no Kanye West said he'll buy a [ __ ]
a house so that's pretty crazy he just
said that in an interview
see let me tell you something that I
believe like I believe that if I believe
that
you you get what you get you get with
your gear like so in order for me to do
something for a [ __ ] you got to do
something for me first but she got to
break the ice
she got to come yeah I ain't gonna be
the first one to break the ice and you
ain't gonna just be able to buy me no
ear pods or some [ __ ] or a [ __ ] pair
of Air Forces
no you got to buy me some big [ __ ]
everywhere if you buy me some forces
then I'm gonna buy you some forces yeah
I'm not gonna hey you can't buy me
forces and then you get a bag Bingo
that's I [ __ ] love that precedent
we're setting yeah like like no you buy
me a Rolex I'll buy you a Rolex Bingo
like you can like you can like you know
what I'm saying you can it's cool to
[ __ ] with them it'll go for anybody if
you buy me a bottle of cologne for
Christmas because you're a broke as [ __ ]
and this is the most unthoughtful Gift
Anyone can get somebody is clone right
then you're gonna get some [ __ ]
perfume bingo I love it you know so you
know you know you get what you give I
love that [ __ ] with me that's my logic
yo what I love about Memphis is the way
you guys pronounce Music
[Laughter]
Man everybody I that's the one word if I
just hear him say it I'm like you're
from Memphis
have you been able to link up uh
somebody who I love as well from the
city who's uh immensely talented and is
having a great run right now is glorilla
have you guys Linked UP not sure it's
coming soon though yeah she's bringing a
great energy she's moving I'm moving we
you know what I'm saying I feel like
together on a song you guys would
[ __ ] spaz because you guys each have
such unique tones right
um that's one of the first things I
picked up about you was like man your
voice your tone is is uh is very unique
right now so
um yeah we was just it's crazy we were
just talking about this [ __ ] today
since I've been out like [ __ ] be like
I'm trying to lock in because that's the
difference I think nowadays is that
people don't get in in the studio
together anymore yeah like they I mean
you gotta look at how much [ __ ] happened
in the hip-hop course in the world yeah
and the hate and [ __ ] is at all times
that's real I feel like the safer move
is to like just send me the session I
mean yeah but like because you know you
go to the studio you don't know whose
entourages are there you don't know what
the [ __ ] going on you know what I mean
like right right
um yeah it's it's definitely
since 2017 we've lost a lot of people in
hip-hop like you said the the
temperature is just a lot different than
it's ever been you know what I'm saying
and that's not even just in rap music
that's anywhere yeah like out here in
L.A [ __ ] is quick crazy
lights because everybody a rapper
like you drop one song and you're a
rapper and then when you die they'd be
like oh rapper such as the kid he wasn't
even no real rapper he just recorded a
song and now they got the game looking
like all rappers dying and then they get
a say cheese TV post because they got
two songs you know yeah the whole time
you want no rapper rapper you one
dedicate your life to you it was your
hobby you know what I'm saying hey at
what point in time did you feel like you
stopped taking like when did rap become
full-time for you and not a hobby
anymore because I feel like everyone has
that period of time where you
start taking this like serious like you
know obviously you start rapping you try
to [ __ ] around with it it starts to work
out when did you decide to kind of like
go ten toes in two feet in on the on the
rap [ __ ]
when I just want to dude that bid that
was it that was the difference it was
like I'm I'm ready like I already I
always had the tenant and like I said
before I went in I dropped the going
straight in song and that [ __ ]
was climbing while I was incarcerated I
went to jail it was at eight million
views and I came home it was like it
went 46 47 million views like Jesus like
it was this without promotion this
without a label this is what I like that
[ __ ] makes the honest way to go this is
without me right this is about you yeah
me like this [ __ ] was growing while I
was incarcerated so I'm in jail I'm like
damn this [ __ ] can actually then I'm
getting Roars and chicks in jail from
all distro kid wow so I'm like damn like
this [ __ ] hey you're on distro kids
you're keeping all the money yeah oh
damn but now I got the distribution deal
with it no I know you're in Atlanta
yeah yeah yeah so that's when I knew
like all right boom I gotta wait I got a
way I can get on the streets I ain't got
to come back to this [ __ ] at all like
I'm gonna get out of jail and I'm
putting both of my feet in this [ __ ] I'm
putting my mind my heart my soul my
blood my sweat my tearing this [ __ ] and
I'm gonna go like I ain't I ain't
feeling none of nobody [ __ ] my
opportunity though I honestly feel like
this is my last opportunity I got in
life
because I'm so so I'm I'm making [ __ ]
like like
yeah that's how it should be man yeah I
ain't I ain't going for none of this
[ __ ] hey we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg hit podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world that's
right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview who were your biggest
influences would you say to your style
to just just on some rappership when you
were growing up who were like your top
three or four guys who were like always
just man if you put 50 Cent
Gucci Mane
Yo Gotti and don't be all in like what's
up yeah you get from this two times put
all them [ __ ] in one all them [ __ ]
inspired me some type of way like yeah
you know what I'm saying God it was just
a
from Memphis like you know what I'm
saying were you young and this was
before the internet you know he was on
tvt records and dropping the mixtapes of
DJ Smalls and [ __ ] back in the day yeah
yeah like Three Six Mafia of course like
you hearing that type of [ __ ] like it's
like it's a kid and like I said like a
lot of people don't know about me my I
had a musical family
so like all like my mama my mama could
sing my my auntie could sing and dance
my uncle could sing and dance so it was
just a musical house like everything was
just always music music music you know
what I'm saying so so you know I grew up
around the music what's the hypnotized
mind [ __ ] like uh did that have like
obviously you know shout out to three
six shout out to Frasier boy shout out
to the chat shout out to Eric you know
the whole [ __ ] little white Triple
Sec triple six how how big of a uh
impact did they have like growing up
just knowing that like there was
somebody else from Memphis that I mean
they were nominated for an Oscar you
know what I'm saying like right right
right
I mean that was big for the city that
was that was big as hell for the city
like like damn unfortunately you know
the hustling flow movie like you know
what I'm saying they kind of solidified
like the culture of Memphis like we like
like their movie was real like
everything about that movie was
authentic like this Memphis right there
it was shot in South Memphis there's
Memphis every day all day
shout out to uh Terrence Howard all-time
performance man yeah I believed it yeah
this [ __ ] was hard this [ __ ] was hard
like this idea what's your favorite
album of all time
foreign
I feel like his life was cut so short
his career was cut so short being from
Alabama you still [ __ ] me up there
people don't be knowing they'll be yeah
like you know I feel like kind of he was
like the guy who was gonna take Grand
Hustle to that next level and really put
on for a state you know what I'm saying
like being from Alabama like
yeah he's crazy man so rest in peace
yeah that was [ __ ] up though like they
they hurt me like they [ __ ] me up yeah
yeah they [ __ ] me up ah well listen
man hopefully we get the album soon
we're gonna be announcing it soon oh
yeah yeah I'm gonna be announcing it
real soon real soon yeah song with Drake
coming
real soon don't do that
don't do that back End Remix featuring
Drake coming real soon it'll be hard
that'll be hard just stay tuned also
well did you guys lose Kodak Black at
Atlantic too
ah
I was gonna say
for some reason I feel like you and
Kodak would go crazy it'd be a lot easy
because you guys are supposed to be
label mates but I'm not sure that's the
case anymore because I already left
hey you know what great timing because
you guys got him now
young boys out of there the budgets are
all yours now because young boys
[ __ ] well hey congrats on the situation
with Atlantic
um congrats on the man just the music is
great bro your energy is dope and I feel
like um
yeah man I feel like you're gonna be one
of them ones bro I almost definitely I
suppose the Ben right here I just I just
couldn't stay out of jail I ain't had
like maybe you needed the jail though
most definitely like a lot of people a
lot of people might look at my situation
like a bad thing like I needed this [ __ ]
that was it was it was a blessing and it
was a gift and a curse it was a curse
because I was going away from my family
my kids and [ __ ] like that like you know
but it was it was it was a gift because
like I needed the discipline I needed
the time I needed to sit down for a
little bit Yeah I need I needed for my
life to flash for my ass shower face in
30 years Jesus so so my life playing for
my life when you get to a point where
you sitting that [ __ ] and you
looking at the concrete wall and the TV
and you like damn this is what I'm gonna
have to do for the next 30 Years
and it you know what obviously it worked
out you only did five right yeah is it
safe to say that had you not gotten
incarcerated that you might like you
[ __ ] might have went a whole nother
direction for you in terms of like maybe
you might not even be here that's why I
don't regret it that's why I don't
regret it yeah that's one of the same
way different life written
and everything happened for a reason but
I feel like you have a choice hmm some
people have a choice you have a choice
to go left or right
what would be before you go man some
advice you would give to anybody who's
watching this who's a fan of you who's
mixed up in the wrong [ __ ] who's kind of
like at a Crossroads in their life
trying to maybe trying to dig their way
out of being wrapped up in streets I
ain't got nothing to say for a
[ __ ] that got their freedom
because as long as you got your freedom
you gotta change but for the people who
and car I got I got motivation for the
ones incarcerated yeah yeah talk about
that like the ones yeah I want let the
ones incarcerated know like man you
gotta change like you can actually come
home and do this [ __ ] you can make a
living not just off of music like like I
said in my last interview I haven't seen
dudes are the same dudes take 20 25 for
coming senior and turning into 80 90 000
come home with 80 90 000 or buying box
trucks and 18 wheelers and [ __ ] from
behind bars you know saying so I want to
encourage them the ones who are already
doing it and the ones that's not doing
it that's still behind bars man get
yourself together because ain't
everything in jail free you get free
draws you get State soap you get free
likes free water you know I'm saying
three meals a day draws and [ __ ] calls
out here
washing powder bleach all this [ __ ]
cause this groceries yeah that [ __ ]
cause you ain't gonna eat no three meals
out here for the free 99 electricity so
I encourage them to man get on your [ __ ]
while you in there because It's Hard Out
Here It Ain't Easy you know what I'm
saying for the ones who free just know
your freedom can be taken away from you
so man take advantage of being free
that's the best line you can have is
your freedom in your life
wow man 25 of commissary flipped it into
90. I haven't seen it bro wow I've seen
it I've seen a dude do 20 I said do do
20 you I ain't see it but I met him like
my last year and a half and man he told
me how he got started wife left whatever
whatever and [ __ ] and then he had like
40 50 609 and he started in my store
and what you do is what you do is
a [ __ ] can come to your cell now you
gotta sell full of [ __ ] you got potato
chips you got the Nutty bars you got the
soap you got everything now say your
family ain't fortunate you say you ain't
got no money and you just won 25 dollars
at the domino game right you could take
this 25 and take it to him and say hey
man uh I need 25 worth of [ __ ]
and he got you got a choice you can send
it to his book or you can send it to his
uh Cash Out To The Streets or whatever
but [ __ ] like me I won't trust nobody
to cash out put this [ __ ] on my book so
you got [ __ ] who doing time they just
build and build and build and build and
build and building building
and for you know they come home 100 200
up like damn 50 60 70 000 like you know
what I'm saying so I want to encourage
them you know what I'm saying to my stay
on your [ __ ] like because it ain't easy
out here
ain't that the truth it ain't easy out
here well look I appreciate you pulling
up man it's all good I'm glad we had to
make the midnight interview happen
I'm looking forward to the album man
save it there it is I say that but
that's two times boom